hi there today I gonna talk about my 90
day challenge 90 day Ukrainian challenge
as many of you know I did a 90 day
challenge in Korean from January 15 to
April 15 three months significantly
improve my Korean since April 15th I
have been going very heavy into
Ukrainian largely driven by my interest
in following the events there and
probably I am putting more time and
effort into my 'ukraine e'en Ukrainian
challenge that I did in my Korean
challenge simply because I have some
very compelling content that I can
actually understand so you know and I
should point out by the way I'm doing
this video that I'm driving into the
interior of BC to Kelowna where my wife
has been involved in a 3-day senior
ladies golf tournament and while she
hasn't scored all that well yesterday
she shot a hole-in-one
990 yard par 3 apparently and she shot a
hole-in-one so she's very excited and I
going up there to join her for two three
days and we're gonna visit with some
friends now getting back to the subject
Ukrainian obviously I have Russian I
have checked to varying degrees
Ukrainian is somewhere between Russian
and polish from what I can see the
structure of the language the sounds of
the language are very similar to Russian
but the vocabulary is apparently closer
to polish there are a lot of words that
I recognize from check and there are
some words that don't exist in either
language so obviously it's a lot easier
for me essentially I've gone straight
into subjects of interest which is
following the events there and I got
stirred up to learn Ukrainian because I
was following the events in Ukraine and
there is a and and one particular TV
program called Shuster live hosted by a
fellow called Shuster who speaks Russian
and probably half the people he invites
speak Russian and a half speak Ukrainian
so I could understand what the Russians
were saying and I kind of had only the
vaguest idea of what the Ukrainians were
saying so I decided that I was going to
learn Ukrainian there are lots of
sources I can go to my favorite source
in this way in a way is Rome at sky TV
television tell about Sonia and horror
masquerade oh and everyday i download
four or five or six podcast from
romaszki radio I've just been listening
to some while cleaning up in the house
here another great source is radio
Svoboda because just about every day
they have a fairly long interview where
they provide matching audio and text so
I import those in the link I also import
other articles from radio Svoboda and
then I subscribe to their podcast
regular sloboda or whatever it might be
and a lot of those texts then are picked
up but it doesn't show up as a direct
transcript so that's why these regular
texts where you actually can download
the audio for this particular text on
radio svoboda is so useful but I also
read from uni on I read from espresso I
follow a bunch of people who tweet and
they might send me off to an article in
Ukrainian Pravda which I import so I've
been importing a lot of text so the bulk
of my reading and listening has been
separate because they simply don't have
haven't been able to find so many
matching text but every day I get or
every second day I get one solid text
from Roger tsavorite which has matching
audio and I import that into link and by
the way it's available in our library at
link so just to give you an idea if I
look at my statistics here at link now
yesterday I saved 184 links that means I
looked up 184 words if I look at the
last 7 days I have saved eleven hundred
and forty-three late
I have action
looked up on the online dictionary
eleven hundred and forty-three words in
the last week and that's I'm able to do
that now because link is so much faster
so I can literally go in there I load up
a text I go from the blue words are the
words that are new to me and I just go
from word to word Bing Bing Bing Bing
mostly I rely on Google Translate big
advantage of Ukrainian / Korean is that
Google Translate is quite accurate for
Ukrainian and it's not so accurate for
Korean so every time with Korea and I I
basically had no confidence in the
Google Translate so I had to go to the
Naver dictionary and look it up so the
whole process was much more
time-consuming with Ukrainian every so
often I'm not confident that the
translation is correct and I go to
lingual and lingual pops up right away
and I select I mean and and so I'm able
to go through these texts very very
quickly I then read them on my iPad once
I've converted all the blue words to
yellow then I can read it on the iPad I
can also read on the iPad those texts
that have audio which I've imported from
Roger swaboda and that helps me get the
pronunciation so every day if I'm on my
stepper typically I like to reserve that
for the stepper it's 25 minutes long the
audio is I like to be on the stepper for
25 minutes and so I listen and I have
already gone through and selected the
words that I needed to learn and I've
read through it once just to make sure
have a sense of the meaning and then I
go through it again listening to the
audio if I look at the last month for
example I have saved five thousand seven
hundred and forty-five links or words in
the last month I have read two hundred
and six thousand words my statistics of
link tell me probably a little less
maybe a little more because I read some
on the internet but it's close to that
so I am just flying at my Ukrainian the
result is that now when I live
the Schuster life like you have these
Eureka moments I was listening to this
one Ukrainian politician I can
understand everything he was saying
everything but there are other moments
when I listened to my film on Sky TV
where I kind of lose the train a little
bit and then it comes back so
comprehension depending on the context
the speaker can vary between 70 and 90%
that's after two months so that's really
good progress
granted it's related to rush me granted
the Czech helps me but and and now the
question is what do I do next three
months you know the idea of a
three-month spurt in a language kinda
has me intrigued so I may go three
months into Polish we have polish Italy
you know I had said I wanted to do
Vietnamese because I'm gonna go there in
the spring but we don't have Vietnamese
at link and let really I won't study a
language if we don't have it at me we're
kind of busy there if I go to bug the
people there and because I had to beg
for Ukrainian now if I go and beg for
Vietnamese I think I'll be told no so
there's Polish I would like to try and
once if I do Polish next which is a good
probability then after that you know
maybe I'll do really take my Portuguese
up to another level because I might be
visiting Brazil and Argentina in the
fall but then I would like to take this
three-month approach to a language where
I have no background no related language
say Turkish again it has to be a
language which we have at link I'm kind
of interested in doing Farsi but we
don't have far seedlings so if I went to
Turkish or finish but turkeys is of more
interest and started from zero I'm
curious to see how quickly I could get
into authentic material using the same
approach that I'm using with with the
Ukrainian rat I mean I is it is it one
or two weeks with simple stuff or you
know how quickly can I get into it I'm
convinced that if you if you have access
to interesting material with audio and
using link that you can actually get
into real authentic substantive material
much much more quickly that's now in the
future
right now I'm focused on Ukrainian